bienvenido de nuevo a Entendiendo la Información y Computación Cuántica, mi nombre es John Watrous y soy el director técnico de educación
en IBM Quantum. Esta es la novena lección de la serie y es la primera lección de la tercera unidad, que trata sobre la formulación general
de la información cuántica. Hasta ahora hemos estado usando la formulación simplificada de
la información cuántica, donde los estados cuánticos se representan mediante vectores complejos con norma euclídea igual a
uno. En cambio, en la formulación general de la información cuántica, los estados cuánticos se representan mediante
matrices de un cierto tipo conocidas como matrices de densidad. Esta primera lección de la unidad se enfoca específicamente en las matrices de densidad
y veremos qué son y cómo funcionan a medida que avanza la lección. Las matrices de densidad son extremadamente
útiles y ofrecen varias ventajas que discutiremos. Nos permiten representar una
clase más amplia de estados que los vectores de estado cuántico, incluyendo estados de sistemas que han sido afectados por ruido, por ejemplo, así como selecciones aleatorias
de estados cuánticos. También veremos la esfera de Bloch, que nos da una forma muy bonita
y simple de pensar geométricamente sobre los estados de qubit, y veremos cómo se conecta con las matrices de densidad de una
manera bastante notable a través de las matrices de Pauli. Por último, discutiremos las matrices de densidad en el contexto de múltiples
sistemas y, en particular, veremos cómo nos permiten describir estados cuánticos de sistemas vistos de forma aislada, incluso cuando
están correlacionados con otros sistemas, lo que incluye la posibilidad de que estén entrelazados con otros sistemas. Esto es algo importante que poder
hacer y no se logra fácilmente dentro de la formulación simplificada de la información cuántica. Aquí hay un resumen de la
lección. Comenzaremos con los fundamentos de las matrices de densidad, incluyendo definiciones relevantes y algunos ejemplos, y
también discutiremos cómo se conectan con los vectores de estado cuántico. Luego hablaremos sobre combinaciones convexas de matrices de densidad, o en
otras palabras, qué ocurre cuando tomamos promedios ponderados de matrices de densidad. Empezaremos con un
ejemplo específico del llamado estado completamente mezclado. Veremos cómo los estados probabilísticos clásicos pueden verse como
casos especiales de matrices de densidad y discutiremos cómo el teorema espectral del álgebra lineal entra en juego en
este contexto. La tercera parte de la lección trata sobre la esfera de Bloch, que proporciona una forma geométrica de ver los estados de
qubits individuales, como mencioné al inicio de la lección. En la cuarta parte veremos cómo funcionan las matrices de densidad para múltiples
sistemas. Discutiremos estados producto y estados correlacionados de distintos tipos, incluyendo estados entrelazados, así como
la noción de estado reducido, que es una descripción mediante matrices de densidad del estado de una parte aislada de un sistema compuesto
que puede calcularse usando una operación conocida como la traza parcial. Antes de llegar al contenido técnico de la lección en sí,
conviene tomarse unos momentos para motivar el uso de las matrices de densidad. Usando la formulación simplificada
de la información cuántica, que no involucra matrices de densidad, podemos describir algoritmos cuánticos como
el algoritmo de factorización de Shor, por ejemplo, sin ninguna dificultad. Entonces, ¿por qué molestarse con las matrices de densidad
o con esta formulación general de la información cuántica? Bueno, hay múltiples razones. Por un lado, las matrices de densidad
representan una clase más amplia de estados cuánticos que los vectores de estado cuántico, incluyendo estados cuánticos donde tenemos incertidumbre o
aleatoriedad. Esto es importante cuando queremos modelar los efectos del ruido en los cómputos cuánticos, por
ejemplo. En segundo lugar, usando matrices de densidad podemos describir estados cuánticos de partes aisladas de sistemas compuestos,
como los estados de sistemas que están entrelazados con otros sistemas que quizás momentáneamente elegimos ignorar, como mencioné al inicio de
la lección. Esto no se logra de forma fácil o natural dentro de la formulación simplificada de la información
cuántica. Una tercera razón es que cuando usamos matrices de densidad la información clásica emerge como un
caso especial. Así, en lugar de tener lo que es esencialmente una analogía entre estados probabilísticos y operaciones, por un lado,
y vectores de estado cuántico y operaciones unitarias, por el otro, tenemos la información cuántica y clásica
descritas juntas dentro de un único marco matemático, lo cual es prácticamente esencial para el estudio matemático
de la información cuántica. Así que si te tomas en serio entender la información cuántica a un nivel matemático, es muy
recomendable que aprendas sobre matrices de densidad. Comencemos con la definición de matrices de densidad.
Para esta definición, supongamos que X es un sistema y Sigma es su conjunto de estados clásicos, y recordemos que
cuando usamos esa terminología nuestra suposición es que Sigma es finito y no vacío, y como siempre podríamos elegir
distintos nombres si quisiéramos. Una matriz de densidad que describe un estado del sistema X es una matriz con entradas de números
complejos cuyas filas y columnas han sido puestas en correspondencia con su conjunto de estados clásicos, y para ser precisos
es la misma correspondencia para las filas y las columnas simultáneamente. Esto significa que las matrices de densidad
son siempre matrices cuadradas, y además de ser cuadradas hay un par de condiciones que deben
cumplirse, y llegaremos a ellas en breve. La gente suele usar ciertas letras griegas minúsculas para nombrar las matrices de densidad.
Rho es frecuentemente la primera opción, y otras opciones comunes incluyen sigma minúscula y tau, que se muestran en
la pantalla. Esto es solo una convención, pero como siempre este tipo de convenciones son útiles porque hacen las cosas más
fácilmente reconocibles. Ahora hablemos de las condiciones o los requisitos que deben cumplir las matrices de densidad para ser
matrices de densidad válidas. Hay dos, y lo que haré es primero simplemente listarlas
y luego discutir en mayor detalle qué significan. La primera condición es que las matrices de densidad
deben tener traza unitaria, o en otras palabras, traza igual a uno. Y la segunda condición es que
las matrices de densidad deben ser semidefinidas positivas. En ambos casos tenemos formas simbólicas concisas de expresar
estas dos condiciones que aparecen en la pantalla. Ahora déjame discutir las dos condiciones con más detalle.
La primera condición se refiere a la traza, que es una función muy importante definida para todas las matrices cuadradas
y es simplemente la suma de las entradas diagonales. Aquí hay una ecuación que expresa eso
explícitamente. Hay bastante que decir sobre la traza y por qué es importante, pero por ahora observemos
una propiedad muy básica: que es una función lineal. Otras propiedades de la traza surgirán y las discutiremos
cuando sean necesarias. Pero para mantener el enfoque en las matrices de densidad, pasemos al segundo requisito: que las
matrices de densidad sean semidefinidas positivas. Este también es un concepto importante que aparece en muchos contextos en
física, química, optimización, aprendizaje automático y otras disciplinas, y puede expresarse de varias formas distintas pero
equivalentes. Una forma de expresarlo es decir que una matriz rho es semidefinida positiva si existe una matriz M
tal que rho es igual a M dagger por M, y resulta que no importa si exigimos que M en sí misma sea una
matriz cuadrada o si abandonamos esa restricción. Otra forma de expresar qué significa que una matriz rho sea semidefinida
positiva es decir que rho es hermítica, lo que significa que es igual a su propia transpuesta conjugada y que todos
sus valores propios son números reales no negativos. En general, las matrices hermíticas solo pueden
tener valores propios reales, pero estos pueden ser negativos. Sin embargo, si añadimos la restricción adicional de que ninguno de
los valores propios puede ser negativo, obtenemos las matrices semidefinidas positivas. Por cierto, si te dan
una matriz y quieres saber si es semidefinida positiva, puedes determinarlo usando esta caracterización. Es bastante fácil
comprobar si una matriz es hermítica, eso se puede ver a simple vista. Es más difícil calcular
los valores propios, pero eso no es demasiado difícil de hacer con una computadora, ya que existen algoritmos muy eficientes para hacerlo.
Y la última caracterización que voy a mencionar, aunque hay otras, es que para todo vector columna s que tenga
un número de entradas igual al número de filas y de columnas de rho, la desigualdad que se muestra en la
pantalla es verdadera. En palabras: s dagger por rho por s debe ser un número real
no negativo. No es obvio, por cierto, que estas caracterizaciones sean todas equivalentes, pero lo son. Y déjame señalar explícitamente que la
notación que solemos usar para indicar que una matriz rho es semidefinida positiva tiene el aspecto de que rho es mayor
que o igual a cero, pero esto es solo una notación abreviada y no significa literalmente que rho sea mayor que
o igual a cero. Rho es una matriz, por lo que eso no tendría sentido. Y tampoco significa
que cada una de las entradas de rho sea mayor que o igual a cero. En particular, hay matrices
semidefinidas positivas cuyas entradas no son todas no negativas, y hay matrices cuyas entradas son todas no
negativas pero que no son semidefinidas positivas. La idea detrás de la notación es que las matrices semidefinidas positivas
son como análogos matriciales de los números reales no negativos, pero esto es solo notación, y lo que significa es
precisamente lo que ya hemos discutido. Ahora veamos algunos ejemplos, empezando con un ejemplo de una
matriz semidefinida positiva. De hecho, es bastante fácil generar aleatoriamente un ejemplo de una
matriz semidefinida positiva simplemente eligiendo una matriz M de forma arbitraria y luego calculando M dagger por
M. Por ejemplo, aquí hay una matriz M que no es especialmente especial, y de hecho
generé esta matriz aleatoriamente eligiendo de forma independiente las partes real e imaginaria de las entradas como enteros entre menos 9 y más
9, así que cualquier patrón o estructura aquí es puramente coincidental. Al multiplicar la
transpuesta conjugada de M por M obtenemos esta matriz, que por tanto es semidefinida
positiva. Por supuesto, hay un límite en cuanto a la comprensión que podemos obtener de un ejemplo aleatorio, pero sí exhibe algunas
características que son comunes a las matrices semidefinidas positivas en general. En particular, notarás
que las entradas diagonales, es decir, las que están a lo largo de la línea de la esquina superior izquierda a la inferior derecha, son todas números reales no negativos.
Además, las entradas fuera de la diagonal de alguna manera no son demasiado grandes en comparación con las diagonales correspondientes,
es decir, la que está en la misma fila y la que está en la misma columna que cualquier entrada fuera de la diagonal que estemos mirando.
Sin embargo, hay más que decir, y es importante reconocer que ser semidefinida positiva es una
propiedad de una matriz como conjunto y no solo una condición sobre las entradas individuales. Así que ese es un ejemplo de una
matriz semidefinida positiva, y puedes generar fácilmente otros ejemplos mediante una metodología
similar. Ahora veamos algunos ejemplos de matrices de densidad donde, además de la condición de semidefinida positiva, también tenemos que la traza es
igual a uno. Aquí hay algunos ejemplos de matrices de densidad de 2x2. La traza es igual a
uno en los cuatro casos, y también podemos ver que estas son matrices hermíticas, así que usando la segunda caracterización de las
matrices semidefinidas positivas de antes, solo queda comprobar que los valores propios son todos no negativos.
Lo dejo para que lo compruebes si quieres. Para matrices de 2x2 no es muy difícil calcular los valores propios a mano,
pero también puedes pedirle a una computadora que lo haga. Por ejemplo, puedes usar la función eigVal del paquete de álgebra lineal
para Python. También podemos obtener una matriz de densidad simplemente tomando cualquier matriz
semidefinida positiva no nula y dividiéndola por su traza. Por ejemplo, aquí está la matriz de densidad que obtenemos al
dividir el ejemplo que vimos hace unos momentos por su traza. Dividir por la traza de esta manera
siempre preservará la propiedad de semidefinida positiva, y ciertamente obtendremos una matriz con traza igual a uno en virtud del hecho de que
la traza es una función lineal. Esa es solo una pequeña colección de ejemplos, y veremos más a medida que
avance la lección. A continuación, tomamos unos momentos para hablar de la interpretación o
el significado intuitivo de las matrices de densidad. Lo primero que hay que reconocer es que puede parecer un poco inusual
que estemos representando el estado de un sistema con una matriz en lugar de un vector. En contraste, en la
formulación simplificada de la información cuántica usamos vectores para representar estados, mientras que las matrices, específicamente las matrices unitarias,
representan acciones u operaciones. Así es como funciona la matemática, y aunque puedes
pensar siempre en las matrices como descriptoras de aplicaciones lineales, no solemos asociar un significado intuitivo directo
a la aplicación lineal asociada a una matriz de densidad dada. Dicho esto, el hecho de que
las matrices de densidad sean efectivamente matrices resulta ser un aspecto de ellas críticamente importante, y lo veremos
a medida que avancemos. Pero para mencionar brevemente solo un ejemplo por ahora: los valores propios de una matriz de densidad dada
resultan ser muy importantes porque describen cuánta aleatoriedad o incertidumbre es inherente al estado
que esa matriz de densidad describe. Una forma diferente de pensar en las matrices de densidad a nivel intuitivo
se centra en las entradas de estas matrices. Recuerda que las filas y columnas de las matrices de densidad se ponen
en correspondencia con los estados clásicos del sistema del que estemos hablando. Así, para cada entrada tenemos un
estado clásico correspondiente a la fila de esa entrada y un estado clásico correspondiente a la columna de esa
entrada. En el caso de las entradas diagonales, esos dos estados clásicos son el mismo estado, y es por eso que las entradas diagonales son
especiales. Una forma de interpretar las entradas diagonales es que son probabilidades; concretamente, son
las probabilidades de que el estado clásico correspondiente apareciera si realizáramos una medición en la base estándar
sobre el sistema cuyo estado cuántico estamos describiendo. En cuanto a las entradas fuera de la diagonal, tenemos un estado clásico correspondiente a la fila
de esa entrada y un estado clásico diferente correspondiente a la columna de esa entrada. Y hablando de manera muy informal,
estas entradas describen el grado en que estos dos estados clásicos se encuentran en superposición cuántica, así como la
fase relativa entre ellos. Puede que tenga más sentido a medida que avance la lección y analicemos con más
detalle algunos ejemplos específicos. Es posible que los detalles no estén claros en este momento, pero por favor no dejes que eso te preocupe.
Esto es bastante informal y solo pretende ser una idea intuitiva que puedas tener en mente.
A continuación, veremos la conexión entre las matrices de densidad y los vectores de estado cuántico, que son vectores columna
con norma euclidiana igual a uno. Solo para recordar la definición matemática: supongamos que tenemos un
vector de estado cuántico Ψ que representa el estado de algún sistema particular. La matriz de densidad que representa el mismo
estado cuántico viene dada por |Ψ⟩⟨Ψ|, como se muestra aquí en la pantalla. Para aclarar esto, los índices de Ψ
corresponden de alguna manera a los estados clásicos del sistema del que estemos hablando, y esa será exactamente la misma correspondencia que tenemos entre
las filas y columnas de nuestra matriz de densidad y los estados clásicos del sistema. Si imaginamos que hay n
estados clásicos del sistema y pensamos en los vectores columna y fila como matrices, entonces |Ψ⟩ es una matriz N por uno
y ⟨Ψ| es una matriz de 1 por N, así que cuando realizamos la multiplicación obtenemos una matriz N por N.
Esta siempre será una matriz semidefinida positiva, simplemente por su forma, y también tendrá traza igual
a uno en virtud del hecho de que Ψ es un vector unitario, y lo veremos con más detalle
en breve. Los estados cuánticos representados por matrices de densidad de esta forma se llaman estados
puros. Aquí hay algunos ejemplos. Primero, consideremos este estado
de aquí, que es algo parecido a un estado más, salvo que la entrada correspondiente al estado clásico uno es
imaginaria. Si calculamos la transpuesta conjugada, obtendremos un signo menos porque el conjugado complejo de i es
menos i, y si hacemos la multiplicación obtendremos la matriz que se muestra aquí en la pantalla. Es hermítica, como podemos
ver inmediatamente con solo mirarla, y resulta tener un valor propio igual a uno y un valor propio igual a
cero, así que es semidefinida positiva y su traza es igual a uno, por lo que es una matriz de densidad, como
era de esperar. Podemos calcular las matrices de densidad correspondientes a la base estándar y a las bases más-menos de manera similar, y esas matrices de densidad
se muestran aquí. Y aquí hay un ejemplo más de un vector de estado cuántico que apareció
mucho antes, en la primera lección de la serie, y si calculamos la transpuesta conjugada y luego multiplicamos,
obtendremos la matriz de densidad que se muestra aquí. Una vez más, es hermítica y tiene
traza igual a uno, y si calculas los valores propios encontrarás que nuevamente tiene un valor propio igual a uno y uno
igual a cero. Y por cierto, esa es una característica común de todos los estados puros: siempre tienen un valor propio
igual a uno y el resto de los valores propios son todos cero. En general, para un vector de estado cuántico completamente arbitrario
Ψ con cualquier número de entradas, si multiplicamos |Ψ⟩ por ⟨Ψ|, obtendremos una
matriz de densidad que tiene esta forma. Observa en particular que las entradas de la diagonal son siempre una de las
entradas de Ψ multiplicada por su propio conjugado complejo, lo que podemos expresar alternativamente como el valor absoluto al cuadrado de esa entrada, y esto es
una forma de ver que la traza siempre será igual a uno. También es consistente con la observación que hice antes en la lección sobre las
entradas diagonales de una matriz de densidad, que nos dicen cuáles serían las probabilidades de ver cada posible estado clásico
si realizáramos una medición en la base estándar. Y una observación final:
no hay ningún problema respecto a las fases globales en las matrices de densidad. Dos estados cuánticos son idénticos si y solo si sus matrices de densidad
son iguales. En particular, supongamos que tenemos dos vectores de estado cuántico Ψ y φ que
son equivalentes salvo una fase global, lo que significa que podemos expresar uno de ellos, φ digamos, como el otro multiplicado por
algún número complejo en el círculo unitario. Si calculamos la representación en matriz de densidad de φ, lo que
encontraremos es que el factor de fase global se multiplica por su propio conjugado complejo, y eso nos da uno, por lo que
efectivamente desaparece y nos quedamos exactamente con la misma matriz de densidad que obtenemos de Ψ. Así que es una especie de
bonificación agradable, y en general no hay ningún problema respecto a la equivalencia con fases globales cuando estamos
trabajando con matrices de densidad. Esa es básicamente una degeneración que existe cuando usamos vectores de estado cuántico en lugar
de matrices de densidad para representar estados cuánticos. Las matrices de densidad poseen una propiedad clave: las combinaciones convexas
de matrices de densidad representan selecciones probabilísticas o aleatorias de estados cuánticos.
Otra forma de decirlo es que las matrices de densidad se pueden promediar entre sí de manera significativa, lo cual es
algo que no podemos hacer con los vectores de estado cuántico. Para explicar esto con más detalle, comencemos con la situación en la que
tenemos dos matrices de densidad ρ y σ que representan estados cuánticos de algún sistema. Imaginemos que el
sistema se prepara en el estado ρ con probabilidad p, para alguna elección de p entre cero y uno, y en caso contrario el
sistema se prepara en el estado σ. Por ejemplo, quizás p es 1/2, así que
podríamos imaginar que alguien lanza una moneda justa: si sale cara, realizan algún proceso que deja el sistema en
el estado ρ, y si la moneda sale cruz, realizan un proceso diferente que deja el sistema en el
estado σ. La pregunta ahora es: ¿cuál es el estado del sistema? Y para ser claros,
nos interesa el estado del sistema de forma aislada, sin tener en cuenta ninguna otra información que pueda existir sobre
qué preparación se realizó. Por ejemplo, imagina que no tenemos acceso a la moneda ni a la
memoria de quien realizó la preparación del estado. Y la respuesta a esa pregunta es que es simplemente el promedio ponderado de las dos matrices de densidad:
p * ρ más (1 - p) * σ. Esto, por cierto, es completamente
análogo a lo que tendríamos si ρ y σ no fueran matrices de densidad sino vectores de probabilidad
que representan estados probabilísticos. Así que esto no es algo sorprendente ni misterioso, sino más bien algo
que quizás sea familiar de la teoría de probabilidad. Hacemos este tipo de promediado todo el tiempo cuando calculamos probabilidades y pensamos
en selecciones aleatorias clásicas. Y el punto es que esto también funciona para las matrices de densidad, pero nótese que
no funciona para los vectores de estado cuántico, es decir, en general no puedes promediar dos vectores de estado
cuántico de esta manera y esperar obtener un vector de estado cuántico válido, y si lo intentas, normalmente obtendrás un vector que
no tiene norma euclidiana igual a uno. Con las matrices de densidad, sin embargo, los promedios ponderados como este siempre
serán matrices de densidad válidas y, lo que es más importante, la matriz de densidad que obtengas representará esa selección aleatoria de
manera significativa. Esto se generaliza a selecciones aleatorias donde hay más de dos
En particular, si tenemos M posibles matrices de densidad y un vector de probabilidad con M entradas, una
para cada matriz de densidad, y el sistema se prepara en cada estado posible con la probabilidad correspondiente,
entonces el promedio ponderado de esas matrices de densidad describe el estado resultante del sistema. Y por cierto, cuando
hablamos de una combinación convexa de matrices de densidad, esto es lo que queremos decir: una combinación convexa es simplemente una combinación lineal
donde los coeficientes forman un vector de probabilidad. Esto siempre será una matriz de
densidad. Y una forma simple y concisa de decirlo en términos matemáticos es que el conjunto de todas las matrices de densidad
correspondientes a un sistema dado es un conjunto convexo. Así que si tenemos, digamos, M vectores de estado cuántico
S 0 hasta S M menos uno, junto con probabilidades p 0 hasta p m menos uno que forman colectivamente un
vector de probabilidad, y el sistema se prepara en el estado s k con probabilidad PK para cada k, entonces el
estado resultante del sistema se describe mediante la matriz de densidad que se muestra aquí en la pantalla. En particular, no estamos promediando
los propios vectores de estado cuántico, sino que estamos promediando las matrices de densidad
correspondientes. En general, un estado como este no tendrá una representación como un único vector de estado cuántico
a menos que ocurra algo trivial, como que todos los vectores de estado cuántico sean equivalentes salvo una fase global, o que todos menos uno de los
probabilidades sean cero. No obtendremos un estado cuántico puro de tal proceso; en cambio, obtendremos lo que se
llama un estado cuántico mixto, donde hay cierta incertidumbre inherente. Veamos un
ejemplo sencillo. Supongamos que tenemos un qubit y con probabilidad 1/2 el qubit se prepara en el estado cero, y en caso contrario
se prepara en el estado más. Aquí está la matriz de densidad que obtenemos al promediar como he
descrito: calculamos las matrices de densidad correspondientes a los dos estados posibles, multiplicamos por las probabilidades correspondientes y sumamos los
resultados. Lo que obtenemos es efectivamente una matriz de densidad: es hermítica, su traza es igual a uno,
y si calculas los valores propios de esta matriz obtendrás dos números reales positivos, y resultan ser dos números que probablemente ya te son familiares
a estas alturas: coseno al cuadrado de pi sobre 8 y seno al cuadrado de pi sobre 8, es decir, aproximadamente 0.85 y
0.15. No existe una representación de vector de estado cuántico único para este estado; no es un estado puro. A continuación veremos uno
en particular: la matriz de densidad que representa un estado cuántico de un solo qubit conocido como el estado completamente mixto.
Este estado aparece con frecuencia, por lo que es bueno tener un nombre para él, y también es un buen ejemplo porque
ilustra una característica importante de las matrices de densidad. De hecho, existe un estado completamente mixto definido de manera análoga para cualquier
sistema, pero por ahora nos vamos a centrar en este estado para un solo qubit, para que todo sea
sencillo. Supongamos que establecemos aleatoriamente el estado de un qubit en el estado cero o en el estado uno, cada uno con
probabilidad igual a 1/2, como un bit aleatorio uniforme. Podemos calcular la representación en matriz de densidad de este
estado de la manera habitual: tomamos el promedio de las dos representaciones en matriz de densidad de los estados. Así es como
se ve en forma matricial, y lo que obtenemos es la matriz identidad dividida entre
dos. Este estado se conoce como el estado completamente mixto y básicamente representa una incertidumbre completa o máxima
sobre un qubit, igual que un vector de probabilidad uniforme representa la máxima incertidumbre en el
entorno probabilístico clásico. En general, para un sistema arbitrario, el estado completamente mixto es el
estado que obtenemos eligiendo uniformemente un estado de la base estándar, y la representación en matriz de densidad será la
matriz identidad dividida entre la dimensión, o equivalentemente el número de estados clásicos de ese
sistema. En este punto esto es solo terminología, pero si cambiamos un poco el planteamiento, veremos una característica importante de
las matrices de densidad. En particular, supongamos que cambiamos el procedimiento y en
lugar de los estados de base estándar cero y uno sustituimos los estados más y menos. Esta vez empezamos con la
expresión que se muestra en la pantalla, pero si hacemos la aritmética obtenemos exactamente la misma
matriz de densidad: es la matriz identidad dividida entre dos. Así que es el mismo estado que antes: el
estado completamente mixto. Esto, como suele decirse, es una característica y no un error. Los dos procedimientos son de hecho
diferentes, pero si lo único que tienes es el qubit resultante, no hay ninguna forma física de distinguirlos
ni siquiera en un sentido estadístico. Por ejemplo, si realizaras una medición en la base estándar sobre este qubit
tras aplicar el primer procedimiento, obviamente obtendrías el resultado cero con probabilidad 1/2 y el resultado uno con probabilidad 1/2, pero también obtendrías
exactamente las mismas probabilidades de resultado con el segundo procedimiento. Y lo mismo es cierto para cualquier otra prueba que puedas
diseñar, siempre que estés analizando únicamente el qubit en sí. En general, las matrices de densidad no describen cómo se preparó un sistema,
solo te dicen qué ocurrirá si haces cosas con ese sistema en el futuro, ya sea realizando
operaciones o mediciones. Y de hecho, las matrices de densidad son perfectas en este
sentido: si dos alternativas distintas producen la misma matriz de densidad, no pueden discriminarse ni
estadísticamente. Pero si las dos matrices de densidad son diferentes, habrá alguna forma de discriminarlas, no
necesariamente de forma definitiva, pero sí en un sentido estadístico. Cuando usamos la formulación general de la información cuántica,
la información clásica emerge esencialmente como un caso especial, y ahora voy a explicar cómo funciona
eso. En concreto, veremos cómo los estados probabilísticos pueden representarse mediante matrices de
densidad. Empecemos con los estados clásicos, comenzando por un ejemplo
sencillo. Aquí están las representaciones en matriz de densidad de los estados de base estándar cero y uno de un
qubit. Asociamos estos estados con los estados clásicos 0 y 1, y por tanto podemos pensar en estas matrices de densidad como
representantes de esos estados. Eso es muy sencillo, y podemos generalizar fácilmente el
ejemplo. Si tenemos un sistema cuyo conjunto de estados clásicos es Sigma, entonces el estado clásico a se representa o se
asocia con la matriz de densidad ket a bra a. Esa matriz tiene un único uno en la entrada
diagonal cuya fila y columna corresponden al estado clásico a, y todas las demás entradas son
cero. Los estados probabilísticos se representan mediante combinaciones convexas de matrices de esta forma, lo cual es natural
dado lo que sabemos sobre las matrices de densidad y su funcionamiento: concretamente, que las combinaciones convexas de matrices de densidad representan selecciones aleatorias o
probabilísticas de estados cuánticos. Por ejemplo, supongamos que tenemos
un sistema X cuyo conjunto de estados clásicos incluye los enteros del 0 al n menos uno para algún entero positivo n.
Por supuesto, se pierde poca o ninguna generalidad al suponer que nuestro conjunto de estados clásicos tiene esta forma. Si tuviéramos un
diferentes conjuntos de estados clásicos podríamos simplemente renombrar los estados clásicos de esta manera y suele ser bastante conveniente asumir que nuestro
conjunto de estados clásicos se ve así, en gran parte porque eso facilita escribir las cosas explícitamente en términos de
vectores y matrices. Supongamos que tenemos un estado probabilístico del sistema X
representado por un vector de probabilidad de la manera habitual; podemos asociar este estado probabilístico con una matriz de densidad
tal como se muestra en pantalla. Tomamos el promedio ponderado de las matrices de densidad correspondientes a
los diferentes estados clásicos, y lo que obtenemos es una matriz de densidad diagonal. En particular, vemos las probabilidades
a lo largo de la diagonal de esta matriz y cada otra entrada es igual a cero. Por supuesto, esto es una matriz de densidad,
así que esperamos que eso sea cierto, pero también podemos razonarlo directamente: es una matriz hermitiana cuya traza
es igual a uno porque las probabilidades suman uno y, en el caso de una matriz diagonal, los valores propios son las entradas diagonales
y todas son no negativas porque son probabilidades. Observa también que cada
matriz de densidad diagonal, es decir, aquella cuyas entradas fuera de la diagonal son todas cero, debe verse así. En resumen,
los estados probabilísticos pueden asociarse con matrices de densidad diagonales. Nota, por cierto, que esto es consistente con la
interpretación informal de las entradas de las matrices de densidad que mencioné al inicio de la lección. En particular, nada está en
superposición cuántica aquí; básicamente es solo aleatoriedad clásica y, en consecuencia, todas las entradas fuera de la diagonal
son cero. Antes en esta serie discutimos el teorema espectral y lo hicimos
específicamente para matrices unitarias en el contexto de la estimación de fase. El teorema espectral es más
general que eso; significa que nos dice algo sobre una clase más amplia de matrices, no solo las unitarias.
En particular, se aplica a una clase de matrices llamadas matrices normales, que incluyen todas las matrices
así como las matrices unitarias. Lo que haremos ahora es examinar un enunciado diferente de este teorema, esta vez centrándonos solo en
matrices semidefinidas positivas, y luego veremos que nos dice algo muy interesante y fundamentalmente importante sobre las matrices de densidad.
Supón que p es cualquier matriz semidefinida positiva, lo que incluye cualquier matriz de densidad, así como cualquier
matriz semidefinida positiva cuya traza no sea necesariamente igual a uno. p es semidefinida positiva, así que tiene que
ser cuadrada, o en otras palabras, n por n para algún valor de n, y necesitaremos referirnos a ese número n, así que sea N
elegido apropiadamente. Otra forma de decir todo esto es: asume que p es n por n. Lo que el teorema nos dice en este caso es que
debe existir una base ortonormal de vectores, que llamaremos s0 hasta s n menos uno, junto con números reales no negativos
Lambda 0 hasta Lambda n menos uno, tales que P puede expresarse como se muestra
aquí en pantalla. En palabras, si multiplicamos cada Lambda K por ket sk por bra sk y luego
sumamos sobre todos los K de 0 a n menos uno, obtenemos P. Esto se denomina descomposición espectral
de P. Cada Lambda K es necesariamente un valor propio de p y cada s es un vector propio unitario de P
correspondiente a ese valor propio. Si vuelves a la lección 7 sobre estimación de fase, encontrarás un teorema similar
para matrices unitarias. Allí, los valores propios son números complejos en el círculo unitario, en lugar de ser números reales no negativos,
pero por lo demás es la misma idea, y estos son realmente solo dos casos especiales de un teorema más general conocido como
el teorema espectral. No funciona para toda matriz: necesitas que la matriz conmute con su
transpuesta conjugada, y eso es lo que significa que una matriz sea normal. Pero de hecho siempre ocurre
tanto para matrices unitarias como para matrices semidefinidas positivas, y más en general para matrices hermitianas, donde
siempre tendremos valores propios reales, aunque no necesariamente no negativos. Así que ese es el enunciado del
teorema espectral solo para matrices semidefinidas positivas, y ahora veamos qué nos dice sobre las matrices de densidad.
Lo que nos dice es que para una matriz de densidad n por n arbitraria, siempre podemos expresar esa matriz como una combinación convexa
de n estados puros, y además podemos elegir que esos n estados puros sean
ortogonales. Eso se desprende directamente del teorema junto con un hecho básico del álgebra lineal, que es que
la suma de los valores propios de cualquier matriz es siempre igual a la traza de esa matriz. En otras palabras, todo lo que realmente
hacemos aquí es renombrar los valores propios p0 hasta pN menos uno y luego observar que, cuando hacemos eso y
reunimos esos valores propios en un vector de dimensión n, necesariamente obtenemos un vector de probabilidad, porque todos deben ser no negativos y su suma es igual
a la traza de rho, que es uno porque rho es una matriz de densidad. Así que es bastante sencillo, pero es
realmente bastante fundamental conceptualmente. Lo que nos dice es que toda matriz de densidad,
sin importar cuán complicada parezca, podría surgir de seleccionar primero una base ortonormal del sistema que sea
el que estemos tratando y luego elegir aleatoriamente un estado cuántico de esa base según alguna elección para las probabilidades.
Si no queda inmediatamente claro por qué eso es interesante o importante, está bien, pero usamos este
hecho con mucha frecuencia cuando razonamos sobre matrices de densidad, y de hecho expresar una matriz de densidad dada
de esta manera es a menudo lo primero que hacemos cuando queremos entenderla
mejor. Aquí hay un ejemplo: recuerda la matriz de densidad que obtuvimos antes, donde elegíamos aleatoriamente entre
el estado cero y el estado más cada uno con probabilidad 1/2, que como calculamos tiene una matriz de densidad que
se ve así. El estado cero y el estado más no son ortogonales, así que esto no es una
descomposición espectral, pero si calculamos una, lo cual podemos hacer con un ordenador o a mano en un caso como este, lo que
obtenemos es esta expresión de nuestra matriz de densidad, donde los valores propios son estos números que siguen apareciendo y
donde los vectores propios correspondientes pueden elegirse como se muestra aquí abajo en pantalla. Y de nuevo, hemos visto estos vectores antes, por ejemplo en el
contexto del juego CHSH en la lección cuatro. Así que eso es interesante: según
la expresión original, este estado es lo que obtenemos eligiendo uniformemente entre dos estados: el estado cero y
el estado más. Pero de hecho obtenemos exactamente la misma matriz de densidad eligiendo aleatoriamente entre dos estados puros,
aunque con una fuerte preferencia hacia uno de ellos: aproximadamente un 85% para el primero y solo un 15% para
el segundo. Así que en cierto sentido hay en realidad bastante menos aleatoriedad inherente al estado de lo que podría haber parecido en un principio.
Hay una forma geométrica muy elegante de pensar y visualizar los estados cuánticos de un único qubit, conocida
como la esfera de Bloch. Solo funciona para qubits individuales; para sistemas que tienen tres
o más estados clásicos, incluyendo dos o más qubits juntos, ya no funciona. Así que es bastante limitada, pero
aun así es una forma genial de pensar en los estados de un único qubit. Podría haberse introducido mucho
en la lección uno de la serie sobre sistemas individuales, pero no es realmente esencial para entender cómo funciona la información cuántica, y también tiene una
conexión muy interesante con las matrices de densidad, así que encaja de forma natural en esta lección, y de hecho voy a explicarlo
de una manera algo diferente a como quizás se explica más habitualmente, usando matrices de densidad para efectivamente
derivarlo; así que si ya estás familiarizado con la esfera de Bloch, esta explicación puede ser un poco diferente a como
lo aprendiste por primera vez, pero al final debería ser equivalente, por supuesto. Empezaremos pensando en
los posibles estados puros de un qubit, primero tal como se representan mediante vectores de estado cuántico.
Hasta una fase global, cualquier vector de estado cuántico de un qubit puede expresarse como
se muestra aquí en la pantalla. Para ser precisos, tenemos dos números reales, theta y fi, y vamos a pensar
en estos dos números como ángulos expresados en radianes. El primer número, theta, está entre 0 y pi, o de forma equivalente es un
ángulo entre 0 y 180°, y el segundo número, fi, está entre 0 y 2 pi, incluyendo el 0 pero no el 2
pi, es decir, cualquier ángulo entre 0 y 360°. La entrada cero de nuestro vector es
el coseno de theta entre 2, que es un número real entre 0 y 1 y, en particular, es necesariamente no negativo.
Y la entrada uno de nuestro vector es e elevado a i por fi, multiplicado por el seno de theta entre 2, y eso puede ser
cualquier número complejo sobre o dentro del círculo unitario complejo. Esto es siempre un vector unitario, o
en otras palabras, es un vector de estado cuántico válido, y para cualquier vector de estado cuántico de un qubit dado, siempre podemos encontrar
un vector de esta forma que sea equivalente a ese vector salvo una fase global. En particular, siempre podemos
multiplicar el vector dado por una fase global para hacer que la entrada cero sea un número real no negativo; elegir el theta que
corresponda a esa entrada, y luego elegir fi para que coincida con la entrada uno. La magnitud de la entrada uno siempre
concordará necesariamente con el seno de theta entre dos, dada la suposición de que empezamos con un vector unitario.
Ahora bien, no es del todo cierto que theta y fi estén determinados de forma única por cualquier vector de estado cuántico con el que hayamos empezado,
pero casi. Siempre habrá un valor único de theta entre cero y pi que funcione,
y habitualmente hay un valor único de fi que funciona, pero en dos casos especiales eso no es así. En particular, si empezamos con un
estado de la base estándar, entonces theta será cero o pi, y en ambos casos realmente no importa cuál sea fi; es
completamente irrelevante. Cuando theta es cero, el coseno de theta entre 2 es 1 y el seno de theta entre 2
es cero, así que estamos multiplicando e elevado a i por fi por cero, por lo que no importa en absoluto cuál sea fi.
Y si theta es pi, entonces esta vez el coseno es cero y el seno es uno, así que tenemos e elevado a i por fi por ket 1, pero esos
vectores son todos equivalentes salvo una fase global, así que de nuevo no importa cuál sea fi. Sin embargo, si theta cae propiamente
entre cero y pi, entonces siempre habrá un valor único de fi que funcione. Y, por cierto, esta posible
degeneración en el valor de fi para los dos casos especiales tendrá todo el sentido cuando veamos la imagen geométrica
dentro de un momento. Ahora calculemos la matriz de densidad asociada a un vector de estado de la forma que acabamos de
identificar. Esto va a ser un estado puro de un qubit. Para hacerlo, multiplicamos el vector
por su transpuesta conjugada como de costumbre, y en la pantalla aparece una expresión de la matriz que obtenemos al calcular la
transpuesta conjugada y realizar la multiplicación. Ahora bien, al igual que con toda matriz 2x2,
hay una forma única de obtener esta matriz tomando una combinación lineal de las matrices de Pauli,
incluyendo la matriz identidad. En particular, podemos obtener esta matriz eligiendo los coeficientes de
las matrices de Pauli como se muestra aquí en la pantalla. Ponemos un dos en el denominador porque eso va a hacer que
todo funcione bien; nada nos obliga a hacerlo, pero podemos, y va a ser útil. Pero aparte de
esta elección cosmética, no hay libertad aquí: esta es la única manera de obtener esta matriz tomando una combinación lineal de matrices de Pauli.
Esto se debe a que las matrices de Pauli, incluyendo la matriz identidad, son una base para el espacio vectorial de todas las matrices 2x2. Una forma
de comprobar la corrección de esta expresión es usar algunas identidades trigonométricas básicas, y en particular, si me aparto un momento,
aquí tenemos algunas identidades que harán el truco. Así que, si te apetece, pausa el video o
toma una captura de pantalla e intenta obtener la segunda expresión de la matriz de densidad en la parte inferior a partir de la primera. Entonces, en resumen, cualquier estado puro de un
qubit expresado como matriz de densidad puede escribirse como una combinación lineal de matrices de Pauli, como se muestra en la
pantalla, con theta entre 0 y pi y fi entre 0 y 2 pi. Observa que tenemos exactamente la
misma degeneración de antes, es decir, que fi es irrelevante cuando theta es cero o pi, y esta vez podemos verlo
de forma más clara porque el seno de theta es cero en esos dos casos, y en los demás no. Vale la pena señalar
que en esta fórmula theta aparece como argumento de las funciones seno y coseno, en lugar de theta entre 2 como en el vector de estado cuántico original,
y eso se debe a que usamos esas identidades trigonométricas, las tres primeras de las cuales son básicamente
reordenamientos de las llamadas fórmulas del ángulo doble, por lo que el ángulo se duplica efectivamente. Y ahora por fin estamos listos para
hablar de la esfera de Bloch en sí. Centrémonos en los tres coeficientes de las matrices de Pauli que no son la identidad
en el numerador de la expresión de nuestra matriz de densidad. Así que ignoramos el dos en el
denominador, e ignoramos también la matriz identidad, porque el coeficiente de esa nunca cambia. Eso ocurre porque ese
coeficiente está determinado por la traza de la matriz que estamos expresando, y las matrices de densidad siempre tienen traza igual
a uno. Ahora imagina que tenemos tres ejes etiquetados x, y y z, orientados según
la llamada regla de la mano derecha, y considera el punto cuyas coordenadas coinciden con los tres coeficientes. Y para ser claros, este
es el espacio tridimensional ordinario del que estamos hablando, donde las coordenadas son siempre números reales. La
coordenada x corresponde al coeficiente de la matriz de Pauli sigma X en el numerador de nuestra expresión, que es siempre un número real porque las matrices de densidad
son hermitianas, y lo mismo para Y y Z. Lo que encontramos es que este punto que
obtenemos siempre está sobre la esfera unitaria, es decir, la esfera de radio igual a
uno. En particular, es el punto que obtenemos si empezamos en el punto donde el eje z positivo intersecta la esfera,
que podemos pensar como el Polo Norte, rotamos hacia el eje x positivo un ángulo theta y luego
rotamos hacia el eje y positivo, o en otras palabras hacia el Este, un ángulo fi. En este contexto, el ángulo theta es
el ángulo polar, lo cual es fácil de recordar porque empieza en el polo, y fi es el ángulo azimutal.
Juntos, estos dos ángulos representan coordenadas esféricas para los puntos de la esfera unitaria, y si
quisieras, también podrías permitir que el radio variara para representar puntos arbitrarios en el espacio tridimensional, pero aquí nos centramos en los puntos de la
esfera unitaria donde el radio es igual a uno; también puedes pensar en theta como si representara la latitud, excepto que vamos
de 0 a 180° desde el Polo Norte hasta el Polo Sur, en lugar de más o menos 90° desde el ecuador, y F representa
la longitud, donde básicamente definimos el meridiano primo como el meridiano que intersecta el
eje x positivo. Si eres como yo, por cierto, y te cuesta recordar cuál es la latitud y cuál es la longitud, puede ayudarte recordar
que la longitud corresponde al intervalo que es más largo: 2 pi, en lugar de
pi. En fin, el punto que obtenemos en la esfera unitaria a partir del vector de estado de nuestro qubit pensando en las coordenadas de esta
forma es la representación en la esfera de Bloch del estado cuántico correspondiente a psi, y cuando pensamos en la
esfera unitaria tridimensional completa de esta manera obtenemos la esfera de Bloch; geométricamente es simplemente una esfera unitaria
en el espacio tridimensional ordinario, pero de hecho esa es la geometría de los estados de un
qubit. Hay una correspondencia perfecta uno a uno: cada estado puro de un qubit corresponde a un punto único en
la esfera, y cada punto de la esfera representa un estado de qubit único salvo una fase global. Cuando trabajamos con
vectores de estado cuántico, esta correspondencia recibe otros nombres, por cierto; a veces también se llama la esfera de Poincaré, por
ejemplo, pero en el contexto de la información cuántica generalmente se denomina esfera de Bloch. Fíjate que ahora podemos ver la
degeneración en el ángulo fi con bastante claridad, porque la longitud no tiene sentido en los Polos Norte y Sur; pero, aparte
de los polos, cada punto de la Tierra tiene coordenadas únicas en términos de latitud y longitud, y aquí ocurre lo mismo. Así es como
funciona la esfera de Bloch en general. Ahora veamos algunos ejemplos específicos de estados de qubit y
dónde se ubican en la esfera de Bloch. Empecemos con la base estándar; estos son los puntos que obtenemos
cuando el ángulo polar theta es cero para el estado cero y pi para el estado uno. Estos son los dos casos en que el
ángulo azimutal fi es irrelevante, como ya comenté. También podemos expresar las matrices de densidad correspondientes como combinaciones lineales
de matrices de Pauli; de cualquier manera concluimos que estos dos estados corresponden al Polo Norte y al
Polo Sur de la esfera de Bloch: el estado cero está en la parte superior y el estado uno está en la
parte inferior. A continuación busquemos los estados más y menos en la esfera de Bloch; de nuevo podemos pensar en
vectores de estado cuántico o en matrices de densidad. Para los vectores de estado cuántico, esta vez el ángulo polar theta tiene que ser pi
/ 2 para que la entrada cero sea 1/√2; el ángulo azimutal F tiene que ser cero
para el estado más, porque la entrada uno es positiva en ese caso, y tiene que ser pi o 180° para el estado menos
porque esa entrada es negativa. Así que estos dos puntos se encuentran en el
ecuador de la esfera de Bloch: el estado más está donde el eje x positivo intersecta la esfera, y el estado menos está en el lado opuesto, donde el
eje x negativo intersecta la esfera. De manera equivalente, también podemos verlo a partir de las expresiones en matrices de Pauli para las
matrices de densidad correspondientes: las coordenadas Y y Z son ambas cero, mientras que las coordenadas x son positiva y negativa
1. Otro ejemplo es la base más-i menos-i, que es similar a la base más-menos excepto que también multiplicamos la
entrada uno por i, la unidad imaginaria. Ya vimos el estado más-i antes en la lección, y el estado menos-i se define
de manera análoga. El ángulo polar theta es el mismo que para los estados más y menos: pi /
2, y esta vez necesitamos elegir el ángulo azimutal F de modo que obtengamos i y menos-i en lugar de 1 y menos-1;
pi/2 y 3pi/2 son las elecciones correctas para lograrlo. Una vez más, también podemos examinar
las descripciones en matrices de densidad de estos estados, y son bastante similares a los dos ejemplos anteriores, excepto que esta vez aparece la matriz de Pauli Y en lugar
de Z o X. Así que en la esfera de Bloch estos dos estados se ubican donde el eje y
intersecta la esfera, y si ordenamos un poco las cosas podemos ver con mayor claridad cómo los seis estados que acabamos de analizar
se relacionan entre sí. Para un último ejemplo —o en realidad una clase de ejemplos— considera los
vectores de estado de qubit que surgieron antes y en la Lección 4, donde la entrada cero es el coseno de alfa para algún número real alfa y la entrada
uno es el seno de alfa. Podemos, por cierto, restringir nuestra atención a valores de alfa entre cero y pi, porque cualquier
otro valor de alfa nos dará un vector equivalente, salvo una fase global, a uno donde alfa está en este
rango. Si calculamos las matrices de densidad asociadas a estos estados, expresadas como combinaciones lineales de matrices de Pauli,
obtenemos la expresión que se muestra aquí en pantalla. Ese cálculo no se muestra aquí, pero es lo que deberías
obtener si lo desarrollas, y lo que encontramos es que estos estados forman un llamado círculo máximo que pasa
por los polos: concretamente, partiendo del Polo Norte cuando alfa es cero, bajando por el meridiano primo y
llegando al Polo Sur cuando alfa es pi sobre 2, y luego de vuelta al Polo Norte por el lado opuesto de la esfera a medida que alfa va de pi sobre 2 a
pi. Y todo eso tiene sentido porque, primero, estos son vectores reales, por lo que la parte imaginaria es siempre cero, y segundo,
el ángulo alfa se duplica efectivamente en la esfera de Bloch, y una vez más eso puede explicarse mediante el uso
de las fórmulas del ángulo doble. Hemos visto que la esfera de Bloch proporciona una representación geométrica muy elegante de los estados puros de un
qubit, donde cada punto de la esfera corresponde a un estado puro único de un qubit y viceversa.
Cuando nos referimos a la bola de Bloch, hablamos de todos los puntos de la esfera de Bloch así como de los puntos
contenidos en su interior. Los puntos en el interior de la bola de Bloch también corresponden a estados de qubit;
concretamente, estados que no son puros; es decir, estos son estados de qubit que pueden representarse mediante matrices de densidad pero no mediante vectores de estado de qubit.
Un aspecto fundamental de la bola de Bloch y de la forma en que los puntos interiores representan estados impuros es que
las combinaciones convexas de puntos dentro de la bola de Bloch corresponden a combinaciones convexas de matrices de densidad.
Intuitivamente, esto significa que la geometría sigue funcionando perfectamente incluso dentro de la bola de
Bloch. Veamos un par de ejemplos, empezando por el punto central de la bola de Bloch, que representa el
estado completamente mezclado. El estado completamente mezclado se obtiene promediando los estados cero y uno, lo cual es coherente con el hecho
de que el centro de la esfera está exactamente a medio camino entre el Polo Norte y el Polo Sur; y de hecho está a medio camino entre cualesquiera dos puntos antipodales, como
los estados más y menos, y los estados más-i y menos-i. Los puntos antipodales en la esfera de Bloch siempre corresponden a
estados puros ortogonales, y lo que esto revela o refleja es que siempre podemos escribir el estado completamente mezclado
como el promedio de dos estados puros de qubit ortogonales cualesquiera. Otra forma de ver esto es
pensar en la representación en matrices de Pauli del estado completamente mezclado. Para que esto funcione tenemos que establecer
en cero los coeficientes de las tres matrices de Pauli no identidad, de modo que el punto correspondiente dentro de
la bola de Bloch queda justo en el centro, en el origen. Y por cierto, pensar en las representaciones en matrices de Pauli de las matrices de densidad
matrices como esta en realidad deja bastante claro que las combinaciones convexas de puntos de la bola de Bloch corresponden a combinaciones convexas
de matrices de densidad: si tomamos un promedio o una media ponderada de matrices de densidad y
expresamos todo en términos de combinaciones lineales de matrices de Pauli, entonces por supuesto simplemente estamos promediando los puntos correspondientes porque todo
es lineal en esos tres coeficientes. Como un ejemplo más, consideremos el promedio del estado cero
y el estado más, que vimos antes en la lección. Calculamos la representación en matriz de densidad, que se muestra en la
pantalla, y tenemos que el punto está en el interior de la bola de Bloch, a medio camino entre los estados cero y más.
También vimos que podríamos expresar esta matriz de densidad de una manera diferente basada en su descomposición espectral, y
eso es coherente con el diagrama y los ejemplos anteriores. Y con esto concluye la
discusión de la esfera de Bloch y la bola de Bloch. La gente suele preguntar si existe una esfera de Bloch o bola de Bloch para sistemas que tienen
tres o más estados clásicos, y la desafortunada respuesta es que no realmente. Siempre podemos pensar en los
estados cuánticos de un sistema en términos geométricos similares a la bola de Bloch, y obtendremos un cuerpo convexo en un espacio vectorial real,
pero si tenemos tres o más estados clásicos no será esférico. Por ejemplo, si tenemos
exactamente tres estados clásicos, o un qutrit para abreviar, obtendremos un cuerpo convexo en un espacio de ocho dimensiones,
pero los puntos extremos de ese cuerpo, que corresponden a los estados cuánticos puros de un qutrit, solo serán
de cuatro dimensiones. Si puedes visualizar tomar una variedad de cuatro dimensiones en un espacio de ocho dimensiones y de alguna manera envolverla para obtener un cuerpo convexo,
y encuentras que esa es una forma útil de pensar en los qutrits, entonces adelante. Supongo que es interesante pensarlo,
pero no es una bola, es más complicado que eso. En la parte final de la lección, hablaremos brevemente
sobre cómo funcionan las matrices de densidad para múltiples sistemas. Las matrices de densidad pueden representar estados de múltiples sistemas, y esto
funciona de una manera completamente análoga a los factores de estado cuántico. En particular, al igual que en una formulación simplificada de la información cuántica,
podemos ver múltiples sistemas juntos como si fueran un único sistema compuesto.
Esta vez, tanto las filas como las columnas de las matrices de densidad que representan estados de múltiples sistemas están
en correspondencia con el producto cartesiano de los conjuntos de estados clásicos de los sistemas individuales. Por ejemplo, podemos considerar
representaciones en matriz de densidad de los cuatro estados de Bell, que obtenemos exactamente como lo hicimos para otros vectores de estado cuántico
antes en la lección, multiplicando los vectores de estado por sus transpuestas conjugadas. Los resultados se muestran aquí en la
pantalla. En esencia, no hay nada nuevo a nivel conceptual, aunque veremos en un momento que sí hay algunas
cosas nuevas que podemos hacer con matrices de densidad para múltiples sistemas. Las nociones de independencia y
correlaciones se trasladan de los vectores de estado cuántico a las matrices de densidad, y en particular encontramos que los productos tensoriales
de matrices de densidad representan independencia entre sistemas. Usamos la misma terminología que
usamos para los vectores de estado cuántico. Por ejemplo, si tenemos un sistema X preparado en un estado rho y un sistema Y
preparado de manera independiente en un estado sigma, entonces el estado del par XY junto está dado por el producto tensorial
de rho y sigma. A esto lo llamamos un estado producto, y se generaliza de manera natural a más de dos
sistemas. Las matrices de densidad que no se pueden expresar como estados producto representan correlaciones entre sistemas, y esa
parte es similar a los vectores de estado cuántico, pero resulta que existen diferentes tipos de correlaciones que pueden surgir cuando usamos matrices de densidad, incluso para
solo dos sistemas. En contraste, en realidad solo hay un tipo de correlación que podemos tener para los vectores de estado cuántico, y
ese es el entrelazamiento. Dicho de otra manera, correlación y entrelazamiento son sinónimos para los vectores de estado cuántico, pero
eso no es cierto para las matrices de densidad. Aquí las cosas son más interesantes. Por ejemplo, podemos describir
estados clásicos correlacionados con matrices de densidad. Aquí hay un ejemplo de una matriz de densidad que representa un bit clásico aleatorio
compartido entre Alice y Bob. Siempre tienen el mismo estado clásico, cero o uno, y la probabilidad es
1/2 para cada una de las posibilidades. Este no es un estado entrelazado —el entrelazamiento no es clásico— pero
sí es un estado correlacionado. Otro ejemplo está relacionado con la noción de un conjunto de estados cuánticos,
que puedes pensar como una distribución de probabilidad sobre un conjunto finito de estados cuánticos. En particular, imaginemos que
tenemos M matrices de densidad, rho cero hasta rho M menos uno, todas representando posibles estados de un sistema particular,
junto con una probabilidad para extraer cada una. Si quisiéramos, podríamos calcular la media ponderada de estas matrices de densidad
tomando una combinación convexa de ellas, pero eso en realidad no nos diría cuáles eran los estados individuales ni cuáles eran
las probabilidades. Lo que podemos hacer en cambio —y es bastante útil hacerlo a veces— es considerar una matriz de densidad
de la forma que se muestra aquí en la pantalla. Este es un estado de dos sistemas donde el primer sistema tiene un estado clásico
para cada una de las alternativas, y tomamos la media ponderada de M estados producto donde el estado del
primer sistema es siempre clásico y básicamente etiqueta cuál de los M estados tenemos para el segundo
sistema. Si no queda del todo claro por qué querríamos pensar en estados como este, no hay problema, es solo un ejemplo de
un tipo de correlación donde el primer sistema es siempre clásico y el segundo sistema puede estar en un estado
cuántico. Una tercera categoría de estados posiblemente correlacionados es el conjunto de los llamados estados separables.
En términos simples, estas son combinaciones convexas de estados producto, y representan esencialmente estados cuánticos
donde cualquier correlación entre los sistemas son correlaciones clásicas. Una forma de pensar en
estados como este es que hacemos una selección probabilística de un número K y luego preparamos de manera independiente dos
sistemas en un estado cuántico que puede depender de esta elección de K. Lo que quizás es más interesante sobre
los estados de esta forma es que así es como en realidad definimos el entrelazamiento en términos matemáticos. En particular, el entrelazamiento se
define como la ausencia de separabilidad: así que si tienes una matriz de densidad y no es posible expresarla en una forma
como esta, entonces por definición está entrelazada. Hice alusión a esto en la Lección Cuatro, y aquí está con algo
más de detalle. Por cierto, puede ser muy difícil determinar si una matriz de densidad dada representa un estado entrelazado,
incluso con la ayuda de una computadora. Matemática y computacionalmente hablando, el entrelazamiento es
en realidad bastante complicado. Mencioné al inicio de la lección que hay algo muy importante que podemos hacer con las matrices de densidad:
describir los estados de partes aisladas de sistemas, incluso cuando están correlacionadas y posiblemente entrelazadas con otros
sistemas. El término estado reducido se usa a menudo en este contexto, y como ejemplo sencillo calcularemos el estado reducido
de los qubits individuales que forman un ebit. Para ser precisos, supongamos que
Alice y Bob comparten un ebit: Alice tiene un qubit A, Bob tiene un qubit B, y juntos estos dos qubits están en un estado
más el estado, y la pregunta que abordaremos es cuál es el estado del qubit A de Alice en
aislamiento. Por supuesto, podríamos hacer la misma pregunta sobre el qubit de Bob, pero es fácil responderla una vez que conocemos la respuesta a esta.
Ahora bien, puede ser tentador decir que no podemos describir el estado del qubit de Alice de forma aislada porque está
entrelazado con el qubit de Bob, lo que de alguna manera podría impedirnos describir o incluso pensar en el estado de A en
aislamiento, pero esto es falso. Es cierto que no podemos describir el estado de A con un vector de estado cuántico
porque, como veremos, no se encuentra en un estado puro, pero todo sistema tiene un estado en cualquier momento dado que puede ser
descrito por una matriz de densidad, ya sea que esté entrelazado con otro sistema o no. Como experimento mental, solo para ayudarnos
a ver cuál es la respuesta a esta pregunta, supongamos que Bob decide tomar su qubit y viajar a las estrellas, y nunca más se sabe de él.
Pero imagina que en algún punto del camino decide realizar una medición en la base estándar sobre su
qubit. Bien, sabemos cómo calcular las probabilidades de que obtenga los dos resultados posibles, y también sabemos cuál será
el estado de A para cada resultado posible, y esas cosas están resumidas en esta tabla. En particular, con probabilidad 1/2
A quedará en el estado cero, y con probabilidad 1/2 A quedará en el estado uno. Y así, como se discutió antes en
la lección, esto deja a A en el estado completamente mixto, y por tanto esa es la respuesta
a nuestra pregunta. Ahora bien, podrías objetar y decir que esto depende del hecho de que
Bob decidió medir su qubit, y que el supuesto de que lo hace es parte de la historia que nos llevó a esta respuesta. Pero
si Bob está a años luz de distancia en el momento en que mide, nada de lo que él haga podría tener ninguna influencia sobre ningún
experimento que Alice decida realizar sobre su qubit; de lo contrario tendríamos comunicación más rápida que la luz.
Así que el qubit de Alice se encuentra en el estado completamente mixto independientemente de si Bob
mide o no. Debo aclarar en este punto que la noción de estado reducido y la forma en que se define no tiene realmente ninguna dependencia en la relatividad
ni en la imposibilidad de la comunicación más rápida que la luz; esta es solo una manera de explicarlo en términos, esperemos, intuitivos.
En realidad hay una definición matemática que veremos en un contexto más general en unos momentos, y que es consistente con esta respuesta
y, de manera coincidente, con la imposibilidad de la comunicación más rápida que la luz. Y tampoco existe ninguna otra
definición que pueda ser consistente con la información cuántica tal como la conocemos. Ahora consideremos los estados reducidos con mayor
generalidad. Supongamos que tenemos un par de sistemas A y B, no necesariamente qubits, que juntos se encuentran en un estado puro
representado por un vector de estado cuántico s. De nuevo, vamos a centrarnos en el estado reducido del sistema A, y para hacerlo
nos resultará útil pensar en los estados clásicos del sistema B. Así que sea gamma este conjunto de
estados clásicos de B. Como hemos discutido antes, en la lección dos de la serie, por ejemplo,
existe una colección única de vectores f sub b para cada B en gamma, para la cual la expresión de s que se muestra en pantalla
es correcta, y en particular hay una fórmula sencilla para estos vectores: simplemente multiplicamos el vector s por el
producto tensorial de la matriz identidad correspondiente al sistema A con el bra B, para cualquier B que nos interese.
lo que estamos haciendo aquí es básicamente prepararnos para calcular qué pasaría si fuéramos a realizar una
medición en la base estándar sobre B y, de nuevo, esto se cubrió en la lección dos de la
serie, así que si realizáramos una medición en la base estándar sobre B, cada posible resultado tendría entonces
una probabilidad igual al cuadrado de la norma euclidiana del Vector 5 B correspondiente, y condicionado a obtener un
resultado particular B, normalizamos el vector 5B para determinar el estado resultante de
A. Siguiendo el mismo razonamiento que en el ejemplo del ebit de hace unos momentos, obtenemos la expresión que se muestra en la
pantalla para el estado reducido de A como una Matrix de densidad, y por cierto, la norma al cuadrado en el denominador proviene de
multiplicar el vector normalizado por su transpuesta conjugada, así que recogemos la norma euclidiana dos veces en el
denominador; las normas euclidianas al cuadrado se cancelan y nos queda una expresión bastante simple.
De hecho, si sustituimos nuestra fórmula para 5B, que funciona para todo B, obtenemos una fórmula para el estado reducido
del sistema A en términos de la descripción mediante Matrix de densidad del estado puro con el que comenzamos, es decir, csai
brasai. Así que esta es nuestra fórmula para el estado reducido del sistema A, suponiendo que el sistema compuesto AB empezó en
el estado puro sigh. Pero también podemos usar la fórmula de forma más general; en particular, supongamos
que el estado de AB viene dado por alguna Matrix de densidad row, que podría tomar la forma K SI brai para algún estado cuántico
Vector s, pero no necesariamente. Se sigue básicamente por linealidad que el estado reducido de A es
determinado por la misma fórmula que teníamos para estados puros, excepto que sustituimos cualquier Matrix de densidad row que
queramos. Como notación abreviada, es bastante común que denotemos este estado reducido con el nombre que estemos usando para la
Matrix de densidad Row en este caso, pero con un subíndice que indica el sistema en el que nos centramos, así que row con un
subíndice A significa el estado reducido de A cuando el sistema compuesto está en el estado row. Los superíndices también se usan a veces
en lugar de los subíndices; básicamente es solo una preferencia personal y significa lo mismo.
Nos hemos centrado en el sistema A por simplicidad, pero también podemos obtener el estado reducido del sistema B
de forma análoga, pero donde la fórmula se adapta de manera natural. Todo es simétrico aquí; estamos
esencialmente solo intercambiando los roles de A y B, y en particular la suma recorre los estados clásicos de A esta vez
en lugar de B, y en la fórmula que se muestra en la pantalla estamos suponiendo que el conjunto de estados clásicos de A se llama
Sigma. Todo esto se generaliza de manera bastante directa a tres o más sistemas. Por ejemplo, si tenemos tres
sistemas A, B y C que colectivamente están en el estado descrito por la Matrix de densidad row, entonces podemos obtener el
estado reducido del par A junto por la fórmula que se muestra aquí, así como el estado del tercer sistema por separado,
que es la segunda fórmula, y puedes considerar otras combinaciones y generalizar esto a cuantos sistemas quieras. Las sumas siempre se toman sobre
los conjuntos de estados clásicos de los sistemas que se están ignorando, y el patrón es siempre el mismo, con la Matrix de
densidad con la que comenzamos siendo intercalada entre el producto tensorial de la Matrix identidad y bras y kets correspondientes a estados de la base estándar.
Para concluir la lección, voy a decir solo un poco más sobre las definiciones que acabamos de ver. La operación sobre matrices de
densidad que describe los estados reducidos tiene un nombre y se llama la traza parcial. Para dos sistemas A y B, la
traza parcial sobre B y la traza parcial sobre A son las definidas aquí en la pantalla. Son exactamente las mismas
fórmulas que vimos hace unos momentos, y ahora simplemente las pensamos como funciones de row y les damos
nombres. Los nombres se parecen a la traza, excepto que hay un subíndice que nos dice qué sistema está siendo eliminado,
o en otras palabras, qué sistema es el cuyo conjunto de estados clásicos estamos sumando y que está siendo intercalado entre un bra y un
ket. Cuando tomamos la traza parcial de row B por ejemplo, que está descrita por la primera fórmula, a veces decimos que
B es "trazado fuera", e igualmente para A. Intuitivamente hablando, trazar fuera un
sistema simplemente significa que lo descartamos o simplemente lo ignoramos. Esa es una forma de definir la traza
parcial, y otra forma equivalente es decir que estas aplicaciones son las únicas aplicaciones lineales que satisfacen las
fórmulas que se muestran aquí a la derecha. Específicamente, si tenemos un producto tensorial de dos matrices M y N, digamos,
y realizamos la traza parcial sobre el primer sistema, entonces lo que obtenemos es la traza de la primera Matrix M por
la segunda Matrix, y la condición es simétrica cuando trazamos sobre el segundo sistema. No toda Matrix de la que calcularíamos
la traza parcial es un producto tensorial como este, pero toda Matrix puede expresarse como una combinación lineal de
productos tensoriales, y podemos determinar la traza parcial a partir de estas condiciones junto con el hecho de que estas son aplicaciones lineales.
Por eso se llama la traza parcial. Esta definición equivalente puede ser
bastante útil porque a menudo podemos usarla en lugar de la fórmula original. Aquí hay un ejemplo que
ilustra esto. Supongamos que tenemos un par de qubits A en el estado cuya Matrix de densidad se muestra aquí en la
pantalla. Este resulta ser un ejemplo de un estado correlacionado donde A está en el estado cero o en el estado uno, cada uno
con probabilidad 1/2, así que podemos pensar en A como siendo clásico. Si A está en el estado cero, entonces
B también lo está, y si A está en el estado uno, entonces B está en el estado plus. Si queremos saber cuál es el estado reducido de A,
trazamos B fuera, y si usamos la segunda fórmula de la definición equivalente junto con la linealidad, entonces podemos
calcularlo bastante fácilmente. En particular, la traza de k0 bra 0 es uno, al igual que la traza de K plus bra
plus, así que esos factores tensoriales desaparecen y nos queda el estado completamente mixto. De manera similar, podemos calcular
el estado reducido de B trazando A fuera. Esta vez es el primer factor tensorial sobre el que realizamos la traza, así que
estamos usando la primera fórmula de la definición equivalente, y nos queda 1/2 * ket 0 bra 0 más 1/2 * ket
plus bra Plus, o en otras palabras, la misma Matrix de densidad que apareció algunas veces anteriormente. Obtendrías exactamente los
mismos resultados si usaras las fórmulas de la primera definición, pero esta es una forma mucho más fácil de hacerlo. Todo esto se generaliza a tres o más
sistemas, pero para este video voy a parar aquí y dejar esto para que lo consideres por tu cuenta. Y eso es todo para esta lección, que
introduce las matrices de densidad y describe los conceptos básicos de cómo funcionan. También discutimos la esfera de Bloch
así como los diferentes tipos de correlaciones y la noción de estado reducido de un sistema. Espero que te unas a mí para la
próxima lección, que trata sobre los canales, que son aplicaciones lineales de matrices de densidad a matrices de densidad que
describen operaciones sobre sistemas. Hasta
luego.